let's get to the trivia shall we if you  get three in a row without us jumping in  with a chance to steal which means you  gotta answer them fairly quickly yeah no  googling no googling then we will send  you an official signed certificate  stating that you in fact do not have  donkey brains  thanks for calling the always sunny  podcast you're on with rob charlie and  glenn  i'm sorry alex but uh you have no such  certificate proving that you don't have  donkey brains therefore the assumption  will be moving forward that you do  indeed have donkey brains and we can't  have a donkey brain man out there  driving on the road so um so we're gonna  have to you're gonna lose your life  you're gonna lose your license you've  got turkey brains  oh we cannot send you a certificate you  will not be able to prove that you don't  have the brains of a donkey  [Music]  you